the nebula by mon cuatro is the world's
most advanced shower head it only uses
50 percent as much water but with a
super high pressure spray click the link
below and use the code Pacman for 10 off
all nevia products welcome everybody it
is a major major 24 hours of news we
have uh all sorts of different things
going on economically including what's
going on uh in the stock market the
expected fed announcement today about
interest rates which a lot of different
people are watching for different
reasons be it geopolitically or
economically or financially or whatever
the case may be we're also going to be
talking about uh foreign policy and
geopolitics today and just a lot going
on so to start with
really major statement yesterday from
the Department of Justice there's been
this question for months now which quite
frankly to put it coarsely the question
is like what the hell is the doj doing
are they going to investigate any of the
Dozen different things that they could
investigate related to what Republicans
and the Trump campaign did and tried
around the 2020 election what is Merit
Garland doing now the answer on most of
those things is still no they're not
investigating but a pretty major piece
of news yesterday and admission from the
deputy attorney general Lisa Monaco who
said there is an active investigation
into one element of the Trump coup plot
which is the fraudulent Republican
electors now I'm trying to think should
I play the clip first or should I
explain what that let's play the clip
first where she acknowledges that there
is an investigation going on then I'll
remind you there's so many aspects to
the 2020 Trump coup attempt that I'll
I'll explain which one she's referring
to
on the issue you raised in terms of
fraudulent elector certifications is has
been reported we've received those
referrals our prosecutors are looking at
the at those and I can't say anything
more on ongoing investigations but more
broadly look the attorney general has
been very very clear we are going to
follow the facts and the law wherever
they lead to address conduct of any kind
and at any level that is part of an
assault on our democracy so at any level
is of course code for up to and
including the president that's good to
see but specifically she says there is
an active investigation going on into
the elector scam now let me remind you
we we have such a in many countries if
we said
the thing they tried with the election
is being investigated it would be one
thing it would be like okay they tried
messing with absentee ballots or they
tried manipulating voting machines or
they lied to people about what the
voting hour like they would be we would
know what it is with the Trump attempt
in 2020.
it's five or six different things and
the one that Lisa Monaco is referring to
is the idea of sending an alternate
fraudulent set of electors to cast votes
within certain States for Trump instead
of Biden so I'll remind you of one state
where they they did it the idea was this
Arizona
Joe Biden won Arizona not controversial
to say that uh in the world of Sanity
reason empiricism and logic Joe Biden
won Arizona
Republicans fixated on Arizona as one of
the states where they said Trump
actually won now on January 6 2021 as as
we now all know
um those electors those votes were
formally accepted uh in Washington D.C
some of them carried over into January
7th because of the riots the idea that
they had was
sign up create a document that says here
are the electors from Arizona and they
would be Republican electors even though
Joe Biden won send them to be the ones
to say Arizona casts its electoral votes
for Donald Trump with the idea that Mike
Pence would be the one to say due to the
dispute and fraud and whatever in
Arizona we are accepting these
Republican electors instead of these
Democratic electors it was an insane
long shot and of course it didn't happen
and Mike Pence didn't participate that's
the scam and it looks like Rudy Giuliani
ran that and that they were trying it in
seven or so states that is what Lisa
Monaco says
is under investigation so that's a good
thing it's a very big deal and we will
continue to follow it of course
one of the things that is unfortunately
missing right now in the sort of
national discussion around almost every
issue in media but in particular around
some of the coveted disinformation is
just like simple gut check questions
what do I mean by that what am I talking
about well all the talk about religious
exemptions to the covet vaccine all
right well some states allow religious
exemptions some don't some organizations
allow religious exemptions some don't a
basic question that you would think is
like the first question you would ever
ask when someone says I object on
religious grounds to the vaccine
would be oh what is your religion
what is the objection
and what other vaccines does it apply to
right when someone says well I I my
religion is in conflict with the covet
vaccine oh okay well where does it say
that and does it also object to the MMR
vaccine does it also object to the HEPA
B vaccine what is the objection Tucker
Carlson yesterday hosted fighter pilot
Lieutenant Colonel Scott Duncan who
explains I am battling the military for
a religious exemption from having to get
the covet vaccine all right well let's
take a listen to what he had to say and
keep those questions I mentioned in mind
well here's one of the sadder stories
which we did more the Scott Duncan is a
fighter pilot he's Lieutenant Colonel
United States Marine Corps he has filed
a religious exemption to the military's
vaccine mandate has not been approved
right now it's on appeal so far the U.S
military has issued just two religious
exemptions total
if Mr Duncan's appeal does not succeed
he will be discharged from the military
which he'll likely lose hundreds of
experienced Pilots due to this mandate
Lieutenant Colonel Scott Duncan joins us
tonight Pearl thanks so much for coming
on and I think of the experienced Pilots
that the U.S military Marine Corps this
country stands to lose you've got to be
you know in the top quartile for
experience that you've flown over 300
combat missions over 200 carrier
Landings I you know you got to kind of
wonder
who at the military is prioritizing a
vaccine over that kind of experience
defending the country but um
what's your conclusion well thank you
sir yeah thank you sir for the
opportunity to joining you tonight
specifically to be able to convey our
personal experiences and just understand
it as an active duty service member of
these views are not held by the United
States Marine Corps or the Department of
Defense but uh we do believe that yes we
have a reasonable argument we've asked
our leadership immediately as well as
our Congressional leadership to inquire
as to really the cost-benefit analysis
of losing several hundred very qualified
aviators the average time and grade for
those aviators is 14 years and also to
just consider the second and third order
effects any consequences of what they
have to offer I'm not unique in my
situation there are many incredibly
qualified individuals with a tremendous
amount of experience and we believe that
that could be a detriment to National
Defense in the event we separate that
many aviators yeah I mean you could make
a lot more flying corporate or for the
airlines than you're making now you and
all the rest of these guys so you've got
to think you're doing this for a reason
a noble reason let me ask you about the
grounds of the exemption that you're
requesting it's a religious exemption
yes sir how would you characterize your
the problems that you have with the
vaccine
well the problems we had personally with
the vaccine and we understand there's a
reasonable disagreeance we do disagree
with the pedigree and the technology
maturation over time that's one issue
the other is just a conviction by the
Holy Spirit and I believe we are LED in
that fashion and we do not have any
peace about the vaccine itself so so
think about that he says it the
technology pedigree and the so what he
said there is complete mush-mouth
mush-mouth nonsense but it could also
apply to a whole bunch of other vaccines
that he clearly accepted because he's in
the military and the military is one of
the most vaccinated groups of people in
the United States Adam kinzinger the
Republican Congressman tweeted about
this and he said
I'm having a hard time squaring how you
can be religiously opposed to a covet
vaccine but took the anthrax smallpox
flu typhoid yellow fever MMR Etc to join
and remain in and that not have violated
your religion this is a very important
point we have to be able to say
uh Lieutenant Colonel what you just said
doesn't make any sense first where in
your religious texts does it say that
this vaccine is not okay and how would
it not apply to the list of vaccines
everybody in the military gets at basic
training adenovirus we have the list up
on the screen from Newsweek Hep a hep B
flu MMR meningococcal poliovirus tetanus
diphtheria varicella and then depending
on your particular occupation
Anthrax hemophilius influenza type B
Japanese Encephalitis pneumococcal
rabies small okay I could go on explain
exactly what this means because the
truth is and I'm not being facetious
here if there is a real basis here and I
know that by real we're talking about
religious texts which are only relevant
to those who follow that religion why
would an atheist or a Buddhist consider
what the Catholic religious texts say
that they wouldn't and I understand that
that this is all self-professed stuff
but if you're going to profess it at
least show me where the texts say
it's a no on covet but it's a yes on
these 10 other vaccines it's not being
asked and even Tucker when he says
explain to me
the Genesis of this objection he says
well it's the pedigree and the
technology and dude that doesn't mean
anything and we should be able to say
and and I know that these are considered
it's considered offensive sometimes to
ask these questions because it's their
religion but if they are asserting
imposing religion onto a civil system
then it should be allowed to ask obvious
questions like all right explain it to
me where where what's the passage or
give me some some verse or explain
explain it to me so that then I can
understand what it is that you're saying
and of course it doesn't make any sense
this guy's got 10 15 vaccines clearly
because he's been in the military but
this one violates his religion we
shouldn't allow it just because someone
says it's My Religion we should actually
get the information if you disagree with
me let me know you can find me on
Twitter at dpacman we're going to take a
very quick break and be right back
one of our sponsors is nebia who's
introducing their newest shower head the
nebia by mon cuatro it was designed by
former NASA Engineers who spent years
researching how to save water cuatro is
the world's best high pressure water
saving shower head starting at just 119
and Quattro uses 40 to 50 percent less
water than traditional shower heads
helping the planet helping your wallet
still giving you the high pressure water
stream you love with four different
spray modes literally takes one to two
minutes to install easy as screwing in a
light bulb I love it I have the rain
shower version I've been using nebia
shower heads for a while now I love
saving the water and I love the high
pressure spray it's really The Best of
Both Worlds nebia the maker of cuatro
also offers sustainable bathroom
accessories I have the soft gray bath
mat and the nebia double shelf the
Quattro shower head is just 190 19 but
nebia is giving you 10 off when you go
to nebia.com Pacman and use the promo
code Pacman the link is underneath this
video the David packman show is funded
primarily by listeners of the podcast
viewers on YouTube people who listen to
the show on the radio or watch on Free
Speech TV who sign up for memberships on
my website that website is
joinpakman.com it's cheap it's quick it
directly goes to support our Daily Show
and also gets you a ton of great perks
including the daily bonus show
commercial free audio and video feeds of
the show which are made available six
hours earlier for our members no waiting
until the clips get published or the
podcast goes out you get the show very
very early in the day you can sign up at
joinpakman.com last week we talked to
you about
um oan being dropped by some cable
networks the extreme right-wing
propaganda Network oan it is not just
oan that some cable providers are
dropping a Newsmax the also right-wing
crazy Network to the right of Fox News
is being quietly dropped by a number of
different cable providers and this is
getting less attention but it's just as
interesting
um next TV reporting Newsmax quietly
dropped by Atlantic Broadband Cincinnati
Bell and other cable operators
conservative channels Carriage issues
emerge as rival oan faces pay TV
Oblivion
um and the article actually says while
the focus has been on one America news
and its recent Carriage struggles
Newsmax has also quietly lost
distribution since December 31st Newsmax
has been pulled off the pay TV grids of
cable operators including Atlantic
Broadband Cincinnati Bell South
Carolina's Hargray Communications and
Central Pennsylvania's Blue Ridge
Communications these are just the Cable
Systems we know about that have dropped
Newsmax now as is often the case the
article says it's unclear whether the
carriage disruptions are part of an
expiration of a master Carriage deal
signed in 2015
um or if these issues are related to the
politics of these channels
um as oan has with its upcoming ouster
from DirecTV new york-based Newsmax has
attributed its recent blackout troubles
to quote censorship of conservative
voices
Newsmax said despite our high ratings
with personalities like Greg Kelly Eric
balling Sean Spicer Lindsay Keith Dick
Morris Alan dershowitz and more
that's funny it's clear Blue Ridge
doesn't like newsmax's point of view
um the cable operators framed the issue
in standard Carriage War terms it is
just business you know it's uh this is
actually funny I've mentioned this
before I actually am in touch with
someone at sort of in a position of of
uh I guess to the extent that you can
have power at Newsmax sort of a powerful
position at Newsmax and this person is
very reasonable politically and I know
that it's it's it first for sure to say
it's just a job kind of diminishes the
corrosive and destructive nature of
these channels
um but not everybody who I mean it's a
product at the end of the day it's a
destructive product it's sort of like
saying well opioids are just a product
it's amoral well no opioids have
destroyed the lives of a lot of people
and they've been incredibly effective
for people in serious pain as well and
that doesn't you know okay so I'm not
it's either way it has an effect but
um Newsmax to me is more interesting
than oan not because it's less crazy
although the content is marginally less
crazy
but because from what I know
the oan people really seem to be true
believers in the insanity in a way that
at least some of the people at Newsmax
are not now it doesn't seem to be
particularly helping them with cable
networks and as a reminder it is not
censorship
not to be on a cable network I would
love for my show to be on every cable
network it's not I'm not being censored
there's just a lot of shows and not
every cable network is going to take my
show if Harvard doesn't want me to speak
there I'm not being censored I just
don't have a right to speak at Harvard
and people may or may not want to hear
from me at Harvard and even if some do
and some don't I don't have any right to
show up and speak there and I think this
is where a lot of these right Wingers
sort of uh deliberately or out of
ignorance don't they don't really
understand what censorship actually
means but Newsmax struggling with cable
networks uh as is oan and we'll see what
their cable Carriage looks like as we
get closer and closer to the November
midterms it actually could make a
difference because they are some of the
loudest voices uh amplifying Republican
candidates in these upcoming elections
which now I mean we're talk they're nine
months away we're nine months from the
midterm elections hey this is super
interesting many of you you I am sure
remember the things that Donald Trump
said about people who plead the fifth
right do you guys remember this
well the mob takes a fifth if you're
innocent why are you taking the Fifth
Amendment right why if you if you have
nothing to hide if you're innocent you
wouldn't invoke the Fifth Amendment
against self-incrimination however we
have now learned that both Alex Jones
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones and
Donald Trump's own son Eric Trump
invoked their Fifth Amendment right
hundreds of times during their testimony
to the January 6 Trump Riot committee
report from Business Insider far-right
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones pleaded
the Fifth Amendment almost 100 times
before the January 6th committee what I
thought only guilty people did that
Alex Jones a far-right conspiracy
theorist and host of Infowars invoked
the Fifth Amendment right against
self-incrimination almost 100 times
while testifying Monday before the house
select committee investigating the
January 6th Capital Riot Jones made the
Revelation during his broadcast that
evening and his remarks were first
reported by Politico as you might recall
Jones spoke at the stop the steel rally
headlined by Trump on January 6th CNN
reported Jones was intricately involved
in planning the event
and the Wall Street Journal reported
Jones helped secure a 300 000 donation
for the rallies costs and offered more
than 50 Grand of his own money to choose
his speaking slot Eric Trump also uh
invoking Eric Trump invoked Fifth
Amendment about 500 times now this is in
a different probe this is in the um New
York attorney general probe article from
a few days ago Eric Trump invoked the
Fifth Amendment more than 500 times can
you imagine
when the Trump organization EVP was
deposed as part of a civil probe into
the company's asset valuation the Second
Son answered only background questions
under oath and cited his constitutional
right to avoid incriminating himself in
response to more than 500 questions over
six hours uh if you only need to look to
Donald Trump to get an understanding
of what it means when one invokes the
Fifth Amendment remember
her staffers taking the Fifth Amendment
how about that
and her ring leaders getting immunity is
now
she has people taking the Fifth
Amendment
four people plus the guy who illegally
did the server you know he put in the
illegal server uh-oh so there are five
people taking the Fifth Amendment like
you see on the mob right you see the mob
takes the fifth if you're innocent why
are you taking the Fifth Amendment wow
interesting question
and then they read a whole list of
charges she's guilty on every one of
them and then what do they say but
that's okay and yet other people yeah so
you guys get the point by Donald Trump's
own perspective by his own statement
pleading the fifth is an indication of
guilt now I have to tell you part of
this is just the cartoony and
hypocritical nature right they're
pleading the fifth and Trump says you'll
go the the other aspect to this is
um it actually is a really important
constitutional
reality in the United States that not
speaking your innocence cannot be used
against you and so the first part is the
cartoonish hypocrisy where I'm sure if
you said to Trump sir
in 2017 or whenever you said pleading
the fifth means you're guilty but your
your son pleaded the fifth 500 times he
would say well no but he's being
railroaded in a Witch Hunt so it would
be different that would be one piece but
the other thing is they claim to be all
about the Constitution they claim to be
all about the Bill of Rights due process
and all of these things suggesting that
pleading the fifth is an indication of
guilt violates all of that so as usual
their stated principle that they are the
primary Defenders of the Constitution
and the Bill of Rights and due process
and then they love this idea of if you
plead the fifth you're guilty violates
that as well it shouldn't surprise us
their principles are of no importance
whatsoever
once the principles are inconvenient to
the point that they want to get across
all right this is a very very disturbing
clip I would encourage you maybe get the
kids out of the room before I play this
clip there is a guy named Alex Berenson
Alex Berenson has been consistently
wrong about just about everything
throughout the pandemic including
vaccines Alex Berenson was invited onto
the Tucker Carlson propaganda Fox News
show last night and Alex Berenson has
now made the principled and defiant
statement that the covid vaccines should
be pulled stop vaccinating everyone says
Alex Berenson and Tucker just nods along
he nods along like his head is on some
kind of uh swivel uh you have to see
this this is extraordinarily dangerous
and remember for context this is
business for Fox
just about everybody at Fox is
vaccinated
fox has a much stricter vaccine policy
than the one that Joe Biden attempted to
put in place which has been struck down
by the Supreme Court the fox policy is
even more strict this is a business
strategy for Fox News Let's Just Jump
Right In
uh it's we're in a very dangerous moment
Tucker and you know I I'm not
exaggerating I think this is probably
the most important appearance I've had
with you in the last two years
um it is it is completely clear now that
uh the vaccines don't really work at all
against Omicron
um in in these highly vaccinated and
highly boosted countries uh rates of
infection are incredibly high and rates
of serious disease and death are also
Rising the Israelis are predicting that
they're going to have more serious cases
than they ever had at the peak last year
um and the idea that we would solve this
with another booster is is just off the
charts insane I have not said this to
you before because I'm pretty careful
and I'm pretty careful with the data but
that's not true these vaccines these
mRNA vaccines the MRNA covered vaccines
need to be withdrawn from the market now
no one should get them pull them no one
should get boosted no one should get
double boosted they are a dangerous and
ineffective product at this point
against Omicron the spike that they make
your body make that you then produce
antibodies to is not the Omicron Spike
and earlier today Tony fauci said we're
not going to give people monoclonal
antibody products because the first
generation products because they don't
work against the Omicron Spike the same
logic applies to these mRNA vaccines and
giving people boosters even if in the
very short term it knocks down infection
rates there's a boomerang effect and
that's what they're seeing in all these
countries we're in a dangerous moment
and these products need to be withdrawn
pull them all cancel the vaccines now
just about every claim Barris and
Berenson makes is false but consider how
easily in just 80 Seconds he's able to
set so many fires and consider then how
difficult it is to put those fires out
particularly in in the minds of the fox
audience which is very receptive to this
stuff despite the fact that almost
everybody at Fox News is fully
vaccinated now as a reminder this clip
aside baronson has been wrong about just
about everything during the pandemic he
predicted the U.S would not have 500 000
kova deaths we're at almost 900 000
already
uh he argued that cloth and surgical
masks cannot protect you against the
coronavirus at all and of course they do
to varying degrees there's countless
peer-reviewed studies on this including
one called an Evidence review of face
masks against covid that's in the
journal pnas which I encourage you to
look at he he's been wrong on everything
he blamed vaccines for causing spikes in
severe illness when in reality the
vaccines prevent severe illness he
blamed the vaccines for suppressing
immune systems which is a total
misrepresentation of how the immune
system works he suggested countries like
Israel suffered from rolling out
vaccines early even though deaths in
hospitals hospitalizations in Israel
among the vaccinated were so low in that
initial period that he's talking about
so he's been wrong about everything
but now he makes these claims to Tucker
last night vaccines don't work at all
against Omicron that's not true we now
have extensive data the vaccines we
currently have are much less effective
at preventing infection from Omicron but
still very effective at preventing
hospitalization and preventing death
which is the point of vaccines he says
look at um or or he doesn't say but if
you look at the rates right now of
hospitalization and death stratified for
vaccination status it is not even close
with Omicron almost 100 percent of cases
in the United States he says there's
more cases in Israel than at the peak
last year well there's more cases in
most places right now than at their
previous Peaks because Omicron is so
contagious but there's still a
dramatically lower death rate up to 90
percent lower and that lower death rate
is particularly in the vaccinated
the data are extraordinarily clear he
says another booster won't solve this
well increasingly people aren't saying
take endless boosters of the same
vaccine in a couple months there will be
an Omicron calibrated vaccine he says no
one should get a vaccine at all the
evidence is clear you should get
vaccinated to lower your chance of
serious illness lower your chance of
ending up in the hospital and and a
lower your chance of ending up dead and
then he says it's this is a dangerous
product against Omicron there is no
evidence that the vaccines are dangerous
when used to fight Omicron and even what
that means is very squishy and imprecise
language this is a very dangerous guy
and Tucker has them on and he just nods
and he just nods and at this point it's
abundantly clear Tucker doesn't believe
this stuff it doesn't make what he's
doing any less pernicious in fact you
could argue it makes it more pernicious
because he knows that what this guy's
saying is untrue doesn't matter in the
end because the decision is still being
made to put it on the air but it's
extraordinarily dangerous none of it is
based in evidence and we'll have the
clip if you're just listening today
we'll have that clip of Alex Berenson on
our Instagram which you can find at
David Pacman show you can also follow me
on Instagram at david.pakman I posted
yesterday a very very strange message
not exactly a love letter that I
received from a viewer you can find it
on my Instagram at david.pakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
so many of you wrote to me and said uh
David you've got to check out this new
interview that Jordan Peterson did with
Joe Rogan um I don't know how many of
you have been following but Jordan
Peterson after I mean I don't even know
that I I feel the need to completely
characterize it but he he basically due
to Medical you know we could call the
medical issues addiction issues he
dropped off the public face of the Earth
for years and then now he's back and
um it might not Shock you guys that in
the context of the covid pandemic he's
sort of on this
um man it's just the problem the reason
I'm struggling is
the the Peterson acolytes
if no matter what you say if it's even
remotely critical they will say you're
not understanding him because you're not
smart enough so you're misstating what
he stands for he's not exactly been a
fan of any kind of Public Health
measures being required uh maybe I'll
just leave it at that he's sort of like
in that in that contingent he reappeared
on The Joe Rogan program and has become
almost a parody of himself I mean I'm
just going to look at some clips here
and again I know I'm stepping in I'm
stepping on a wasp's nest here because
everybody's going to write in who loves
this guy and say David you are so
ignorant that you don't have the
capacity to understand what he's saying
what he's saying does make sense but I
encourage you to prove that to me tell
me that what he says here makes any
sense other than being the exact type of
nothing means anything post-modern
nonsense that he claims to be against
take a look at this it's hard to sort
out the climate change one is a weird
one so that one that's because there's
no such thing as climate right climate
and everything are the same word and I
that's what bothers me about the climate
change types it's like
this is the types people who are like oh
here's the science those types bother
him something that bothers me about it
technically it's like
climate is about everything so okay
but your models aren't based on
everything your models are based on a
set number of variables yeah so that
means you've reduced the variables which
are everything
to that set
well how did you decide which set of
variables to include in the equation if
it's about everything
and that's not just a criticism that's
like if it's about everything your
models aren't right because your models
do not encount model everything what do
you mean now what's crazy about this is
when people say climate is about
everything
I mean listen I correct me if I'm wrong
but when when we say climate is about
everything what I think of is
um there's these meta issues in in
society right and those meta issues are
uh you know our economic system
um Access to Health Care
media
and climate and what I mean by that is
if you care about abortion or you care
about net neutrality or you care about
whatever
if you are unable to even sustain
yourself economically it's hard to be an
activist because you're like where's my
next meal going to come from
if you don't have access to health care
it's hard to be an activist for what
matters to you because you're sick and
you don't have care and climate is in
that meta issue category in that if we
have systemic climate change that
damages the planet and creates death
from pollution and all these you know
flooding Etc it's hard to be an activist
for abortion when you're being forced to
relocate because of rising sea level so
that's a completely reasonable way to
say climates about everything but what
Jordan Peterson is saying is nonsense
and people will say I I scroll down
right now on YouTube David you aren't on
you're you're not understanding the
Brilliance of this man all of these
claims are indefeasible anytime it
sounds like he makes no sense you can
say you just don't understand what he's
saying it makes perfect sense
um here's another
clip where they talk about
um I guess this is about race and how
like when you say someone is white their
skin is not literally white and when you
say someone is black their skin is not
literally black it's like this is a I
remember this conversation in fifth
grade in fifth grade we would say I'm
not really I remember a conversation
with the teacher I'm not really white my
skin is like tan
and two black kids in the class would
say I'm not really black my skin is
brown and we were we were told that the
we're not literally guys this is two
grown men doing this depending on who
you ask either you're a voice of reason
and rationality and
and uh you know uh personal
responsibility or you're a voice of
intolerance and bigotry and anger and
hateful sexual oppression what did
Michael Prejudice Dyson call you and
mean every white man yeah and and a mean
angry white man yeah hilarious yeah yeah
and I mean at all that's what's dumb
about that statement it's you're not
mean at all I am white actually that's a
lie too I'm kind of tan and he was
actually not black he was sort of brown
because I'm I'm darker than you yeah
it's ridiculous yeah but neither of us
are white well I'm Italian and he was
brown not black well isn't that weird
yeah it's really weird black and white
thing is so strange because the shades
are tan and brown there's such a
spectrum of shades of people I I had
this conversation when I was 10 with our
teacher I remember every people saying
to the teacher can you explain why we're
called White and they're we figured this
out in fifth grade guys well unless
you're talking to someone who is like
100 African from the darkest place where
they're not wearing any clothes all day
and they've developed all that melanin
to protect themselves from the Sun you
know even the term black is weird you're
not really black unless you aren't
wearing clothes all day this is crazy
guys this there this there are people
who worship this
um here decode this one and and I
there's people saying this is brilliant
here's Peterson talking about music
theory and I I mean you just you have to
see it seems like a parody so let's
think about what music is yes first of
all it's it's a pattern so non-pattern
music is noise it's a pattern but then
it isn't one pattern it's multiple
patterns
layered on top of one another in a
harmonious manner and in a manner that
indicates
in some sense communication between all
the patterned layers because they have
to go together and so
what's the world
while the world's made of objects it's
like no it's not it's made of patterns
so music is just like the world
because the world's made of patterns and
then music
has layered patterns that are all moving
together in a harmonious manner the the
thing that is frustrating to me about
this is that I'm not saying Jordan
Peterson's a dumb guy but there's this
thing that happens where it's very
common that with lots of public
intellectuals the way in which they
speak is not particularly accessible to
lots of people and it starts to be sort
of like well I believe that they're
really brilliant so therefore the fact
that I don't really get this is probably
my deficit and I'm sure that everything
they're saying is great this is an
example of where like some of the stuff
he's saying is kind of uncontroversial
but it's all being tied together in what
truly is a nonsense word salad and
um it it doesn't mean that there's
nothing here of substance but this is
not exactly you know the
um the reaction that this clip is
getting as if this is some incredible
brilliant thing it's it's really not and
it has to be okay for us to say that the
these are very strange rantings
and so what do you do when you hear that
especially if it's got a beat well then
you move your body and you want to right
the music calls to you to move your body
so now you're moving your body in sync
with the patterned layers of the world
that's meaning and then there's more to
it so that's so cool is music is an
analog of the structure of existence
itself and it calls to you to take part
in that and then so maybe you dance by
yourself or maybe even better you dance
with someone else and so then you both
bring your bodies into man I mean I just
I just don't hear here's one about
protected classes I think people are
going after this is part of the cultural
War stuff where now you can't joke
anymore comedy for a different thing
today because they're going after comedy
for a literal literal representation of
what the words mean if you put them in
print
and that's nonsense yeah that's not what
a comedian yeah well they're doing that
they're doing that because there are
some things they believe that can't be
made fun of yeah but the really what
they're doing is just looking for
targets they're playing a game the game
the rules of the game have been
established comedy violates the rules of
the game yeah comedy take those things
well there's a lot of things you can't
joke about you can't joke sacred things
yeah there's there's protected classes
now we all know what they are we're able
to bring them up you know whether it's
trans people gay people people of color
and again this is like the perfect way
to make it seem like oh you know
liberals just don't want anybody to have
fun you can't have fun anymore it's just
they don't they don't want any fun of
course the the real the the truth about
comedy and joking about things that that
are sometimes seen as sacred the truth
is context and intent matters when we
make jokes about
Jews or blacks or gays or or whatever
and of course you can find people who
would say you you can never make any
joke ever at the expense of these 10
groups that's a very small portion of
people and leftists like me and others
understand
context and understand
considering intent and these can be
blurry areas but to make it seem as
though that it's just common you can't
do comedy anymore it's just not allowed
if you have these things it's just not
true all right here's the last one and
here's Jordan Peterson explaining uh the
book The Bible versus the idea of the
Bible uh I know I know
so I just walked through the Museum of
the Bible in Washington that was very
cool it's a very cool Museum so the
structure that's what yeah is what I
figured out I mean I just figured this
out this week
so it was a cool it was a cool thing to
walk through because
it's it's chronological they have one
floor which is the history of the Bible
okay that's not exactly that it's really
what it is is the history of the book ah
now in many ways the first book was the
Bible I mean literally because okay so
wait a second
the floor is about the history of the
Bible
but it's not about the history of the
Bible it's about the history of the book
and the first book was the Bible okay at
one point there was only one book right
like as far as our Western culture is
concerned there's one book and now are
we saying literally one copy or there
was one Tome well literally there was
only one book ah okay and that book was
the Bible and then before it was the
Bible it was a you know it was Scrolls
and it was wait so the book that was the
Bible existed before it was a book or it
was existed before it was the Bible
writings on Papyrus and but it was we
were starting to aggregate written texts
together and it went through all sorts
of technological Transformations and
then it became books that everybody
could buy the book everybody could buy
and the first one of those was the Bible
and so how many books are there now it
became all sorts of books that everybody
could buy
but all those books in some sense
emerged out of that underlying book and
that book itself the Bible isn't a book
it's a library oh it's not a book at all
uh guys
okay bring it on guys come come tell me
I don't understand the genius of that
come tell I'm ready for it I'm ready for
it
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's hit a couple of other things here
um as we continue with today's show we
continue to wonder about what the 2024
um presidential election is going to
look like and a big part of that is is
Joe Biden going to run for reelection we
don't have an answer to that question
yet another part of it is is Donald
Trump going to run for the Republican
primary and we don't have an answer to
that yet either there is a new poll out
which says that as of right now that's
basically a dead heat race Biden versus
Trump if that were to be it I believe it
was about 45 for each a tie
statistically a tie within the margin of
error and we can of course raise
questions about how valuable is a poll
uh I guess we are two years and nine
months so 24 33 months from that
election
it's probably not particularly valuable
other than to tell us that as of right
now there is still great appetite from
tens of millions of people in this
country for Donald Trump to be president
again as I've said before
um I believe that a big factor in
whether Trump will or won't run again is
Trump's Health in 2023 and 2024. he's
not a particularly healthy guy he's not
a particularly young guy and it's a
statistical reality that his health in
2024 may not lend itself to a
presidential campaign I don't know and
I'm not wishing him harm I'm just saying
it's aside from will he believe he can
win
will he be distracted with something
else whatever the health issue is is a
real question and I'm not saying it's
not a real question for Joe Biden either
um that being said we are starting to
see signs of interest from Donald Trump
in running in 2024. one of those signs
of interest is that almost at the turn
of the New Year Trump has already
restarted rallies doing a rally in
Florence Arizona on January 15th he'll
be doing a rally in Conroe Texas where
we will have a correspondent by the way
this Saturday January 29th so he seems
very interested in being involved and
continuing to be sort of a king maker in
the context of the midterms in order to
then justify running in 2024. here's
another just little hint
this is Donald Trump golfing which he
does a lot now and some kind of
sycophant who's filming him teeing off
refers to him as the 45th president of
the United States and then Donald Trump
says the 45th and the 47th just another
little sign that indeed he may be
planning on running take a look
[Music]
we'll be lucky if we're up
first on G
45th president of the United States 45th
and 47th yes
I'm sure everybody tells them how great
his tee shot is right no matter how good
it is
let's see
beautiful
game
I think it's pretty boring to be middle
all the time
yes exactly all right so you know I
don't know how much we we need to or
should
um read into that but needless to say
it's just another little sign another
small indicator that indeed uh Donald
Trump may may be planning to run in 2024
and the scariest part is as of right now
if the election were held today he he
might actually win uh okay Tucker
Carlson is going full
anti-Semitic coddling
with a very special special about how
dangerous 91 year old Holocaust Survivor
George Soros is to the country and to
the world
they're not even pretending anymore okay
um Tucker Carlson is this is a Tucker
Carlson original called Hungary versus
Soros the fight for civilization this
will be streaming today the promo image
which we have on screen has an ominous
looking uh half face shot of George
Soros who is really uh they they are
pointing and and fingering Public Enemy
Number One 91 year old Holocaust
Survivor who donates to Liberal causes
George Soros now as many of you know
many many of you might not understand
what like what does that mean it's not
it's not by definition anti-semitic and
you're absolutely right
um but this is one of the oldest tropes
now which is the conspiracy of wealthy
Jewish individuals to take control of
society often to make it communist or
socialist which is crazy because George
Soros is like the ultimate capitalist to
look at how he's made his money
um and uh very very often if you start
following you if you start following
anti-vaxx if you start following Shadow
government if you start any of these
conspiracy theories you follow them
follow the follow them there you'll find
that the Jews are actually what
underlies this in uh in many different
cases so here's Tucker Carlson I guess
being interviewed by other Fox people
about Soros and the special I mean it's
just a lot why anyone who says that is
either lying or doesn't know anything GG
so I'm going to ask a super naive
question because that's what I do
um I'm like everybody here infuriated by
the funding of the these Progressive
DA's by uh these sorts I guess it's open
Society or whatever it's called so I do
and I look I look him up and I go okay
he actually sounds like in the 80s I
remember in the 80s how beloved he was
because he helped
SSR if my if my memory is correct and I
remember reading about it National
Review and the American spectator and
I'm reading about his past and I go you
know his dad was in Siberia in a
siberian prison he escaped from Nazi
Germany he helped with the fall of USSR
does is he aware that his money is being
used to destroy America is this is
something where he's not paying
attention to it because he's in his 90s
I told you it was a naive question well
I wouldn't just say America I would say
the West right Western Civilization all
of West George Soros at 91 is hell-bent
on the destruction of Western
Civilization is his Target and I know a
lot of people who know Soros personally
and some people have done business with
him every single person knows him says
this is one of the smartest most
interesting people in the world and I
believe that and I'm impressed by it but
his program for the past 15 years at
least has been to make the societies he
focuses on more dangerous dirtier less
Democratic more disorganized more at war
with themselves
adhesive in other words it's a program
of Destruction aimed at the West now I
don't you know I don't know what his
motive is I'm certainly not going to
guess people are complicated he clearly
is but that's what that program is so
let's not pretend it's a political
program it's not increasing the number
of murders in the country what is that
it's an attack on the country and that's
what he's doing and of course these
claims are absurd the idea that George
Soros is going out there saying let's
see how we can get more murders going on
I mean it's quite literally the
caricature of the uh clever Rich Jewish
guy behind the scenes figuring out how
to make everything and it's like how is
that even better for him and I'm sure
they have some way I'm sure they have
some way to explain how increasing the
number of of murders is somehow good for
soros's long game I mean he's 91 but he
has some long game through which
increasing murders is going to be good
for him they're not even pretending
anymore guys and so that's the special
that Fox News is going to be running
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 David P here is a
voicemail from someone who caught the
show on our broadcast uh affiliate a
Free Speech TV now many some of you may
know some of you may not
our show is on nightly on satellite
television that's DirecTV and Dish
Network uh the channel is called Free
Speech TV on DirecTV I believe it's
Channel 348 I hope they haven't changed
the channel lineup I think it's 348. on
Dish Network it's Channel again I hope
it hasn't changed nine four one five
here is a viewer who caught us on Free
Speech TV and he doesn't believe the
name Free Speech TV for the channel is
appropriate
take a listen to this Buckle in
I wanted to make sure I got the right
line I am
I've got a message for you that I'm
still working on I'm writing off this is
a draft message bear that in mind a lot
of information down about your
your network and
why you call yourself Free Speech TV I
don't understand that you people sound
like a bunch of Socialist Communist
idiots
is that it
still on the phone
background noise
sir please hang up okay
um you know this continues to be a funny
thing
I am criticized daily both because one
we have sponsors
and this is how you know I fund my life
and how my employees are paid the fact
that the show makes money
so I'm told the show the show is too
capitalists it's two capitalists to show
because it it make it's financially
sustainable
and this is a socialist or communist
show now of course anyone who watches
would know
really the perspective of this program
is social democracy which is a regulated
form of capitalism we allow markets to
direct resources within many areas but
we say in certain areas we should be out
of the market Health Care education okay
you guys you guys get it you guys get it
um but it it really is fascinating to
daily be criticized for being too
capitalist of a show
and too communistic of a show I don't
expect that to change anytime soon we
have such a great bonus show for you
today Nancy Pelosi is running for
re-election
and
there are people writing in saying David
she's in her 80s it's it's that's it
it's time to go we need a younger
speaker of the house or whatever the
case may be I have some people emailing
me saying David Nancy Pelosi has an
opponent
but her opponent has been accused of
sexual harassment so I mixed like should
I support her I'm not really sure a lot
of questions when it comes to the Nancy
Pelosi reelection which we will be
talking about on the bonus show secondly
the FDA has stopped the use of a
particular monoclonal antibody treatment
for covid because it doesn't seem
effective against Omicron
and Florida is pushing back saying now
we want to use it anyway and Ron
DeSantis sort of doesn't seem to
understand how simple math Works in his
defense of that type of monoclonal
antibody we will talk about that and we
do have Olympics coming to China
and ahead of the Olympics there are some
abrupt and uh very harsh lockdowns
looming in Beijing which we will discuss
on today's bonus show should there even
be Olympics going on we will talk about
all of it on today's bonus show get
instant access by becoming a member at
joinpakman.com and this Saturday we will
have a correspondent doing interviews of
trumpists live at the Trump rally in
Conroe Texas I hope you will join me at
6 00 P East 3 p West
uh on YouTube and now I'm trying to on
YouTube twitch and Facebook we will be
live in Conroe Texas with a
correspondent and then have the Trump
rally and the entire thing but for today
make sure you sign up at joinpakman.com
and get instant access to today's bonus
show I will see you then
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the nebia by mon
cuatro is the world's most advanced
shower head it only uses 50 percent as
much water but with a super high
pressure spray click the link below and
use the code Pacman for 10 off all nebia
products